today I want to talk about the benefits
of a non-rules based program of language
learning and language instruction the
last video I made I talked about this
book The Mind within the net by Manfred
Spitzer where he talks about how the
brain learns and I drew some conclusions
from that conclusions as to how the
brain learns how the brain based on
being bombarded with events or with
words or with structures exposure to the
language input gradually the brain
develops its own rules about how the
language Works in other words those
rules cannot be instructed the rules are
developed Naturally by the brain and I
talked about how the hippocampus which
is the short term and medium-term memory
tries to get access to as many say
events or words or facts or things of
that nature that it holds on to for a
short period of time and then gradually
pumps it into the cortex now there are
some very important benefits from this
non-rules based language learning
approach the first one is that we
shouldn't doubt ourselves I talked about
how children at play it's an opportunity
for them to experiment in a relatively
safe environment there can be no
catastrophic event it's not like going
hunting in the old days with their
parents where they might cause a major
catastrophe to happen it's safe
experiment interact with people
gradually through this experience
acquiring knowledge so that's how we
learn languages we learn languages
through being exposed much like the
child at play in fact we should be like
the child at play so we are listening we
are reading and we are speaking and when
we are speaking we shouldn't doubt
ourselves we shouldn't try to remember a
rule is this correct we should rely more
on the natural process of whatever the
cortex or the long-term acquisition of
ability knowledge longer term knowledge
whatever state it is at and whether what
you retrieve at this time is right or
wrong none of that should matter you
should just go with your instinct don't
second guess yourself any more than the
child at play is going to second guess
him or herself Just go with it I think
we can just rely on the process it
doesn't really matter if you make a
mistake you aren't going to do better by
trying to refer to what crashing talks
about as the affective filter in other
words second guessing yourself based on
some rule just rely on whatever comes
out because it's a gradual process of
learning and you just have to go with
whatever you got and you'll probably be
better that way than if you
self-consciously try to refer to a rule
so don't doubt yourself the second thing
that I think is very beneficial from
this understanding of how language
learning works is that we should focus
on being active in other words rather
than worrying about what we have
achieved in the language and I think
this message goes as much to the
Learners who are always hoping that they
would be better than they are as well as
the teachers who want to teach and test
and show X points out of ten the teacher
can't teach you the rule testing you on
the rule doesn't matter you have to just
rely on staying so active that there are
enough language events words sounds
sentences exposure to the language
coming at you and that the hippocampus
then if we take that model is then
passing on to the longer term cortex
area to develop your skill in the
language as long as you keep doing that
the more active you are the more things
are being pushed into your cortex the
sort of longer term processing area the
better so all you need to worry about is
not how well you've done on the last
test or how well you're going to do on
the next test you just have to keep
active so that simplifies the task at
hand so if you can go out and find
interesting things to do in the language
or vary between interesting but
difficult texts and easier but text
where there's perhaps more repetition of
familiar words you keep doing this kind
of stuff pumping it into your cortex
eventually you're going to improve but
you improve slowly the third thing
that's beneficial about understanding
this way of learning is something that I
have observed on many occasions and that
is that if you have had an enough
activity in the language have done
enough listening and reading have read
books and so forth if you then leave the
language for a while when you go back to
it because everything is stored in your
long-term memory all of that stuff is
still there somewhere in the cortex you
may not be able to retrieve it right
away but as you reactivate the language
you reactivate all of these associations
that were part of how you acquired the
words associations with sounds with
context with similar words or different
words or whatever those associations
were there's this network of
associations that connect all these
words in some way and so even if you
leave the language if you've got it to a
sufficient level you don't have to worry
and in fact as I have said I have often
found that when I go back to a language
that I have left in what I termed a
period of benign neglect of course in
the short term I forget certain words
but in the long term I am better than
ever so I am better today in even those
languages that I speak quite well well
but which I didn't spend much time on
because I was learning new languages but
when I go back to my Japanese or my
Chinese or my French or my Spanish I'm
actually better now than I was before
because all of that activity somehow has
improved my ability to retrieve the
language use the language in ways that I
don't fully understand but I am
convinced that if we take the position
that we are not going to learn rules and
extrapolate from rules but instead we're
going to expose ourselves to as much of
the language as possible hopefully in
interesting context but as long as we're
exposed all the time and we're not
doubting ourselves when we use the
language we're like the child at play
and we stay as active as we possibly can
pumping stuff into our cortex then after
an absence and we go back to that
language we're going to find that we are
at least as good as we ever were and
possibly better so there are lots of
advantages to taking this non-rules
based approach to language learning